I was I wrong a few weeks ago to somehow
give the impression to people that I was
praising those men who I successfully
opposed time and again yes I was I
regret it and I'm sorry for any the pain
or misconception they may have caused
anybody finally Joe Biden apologized not
for being a sleepy veep
but for admitting that he could work
with people he disagreed with including
awful Democrats from his very own party
to make his point he used
segregationists who were the backbone of
the Democratic Party but unfortunately
we live in a world where deliberate
misinterpretation is weaponized Kamala
Harris new Biden wasn't being racist and
that he wasn't complimenting
segregationists on the contrary it was
their heinous 'no stats served the
example well everybody knows that but as
long as there's room enough to slide in
a gotcha there's room enough to gain an
edge among Democrats saying gotcha is
speaking truth to power so Joe's example
of being able to work with racists
became Joe throwing slumber parties with
cross burners while they braided each
other's hair and wrote each other love
poems in their yearbooks
so now Biden limps along like an injured
gazelle on the Serengeti unaware that
his apology is but the first in a long
line of ones he'll be giving because one
is never enough and two is just the
appetizer
he'll be apologizing until the dessert
is served and the check comes and Joe's
been around a long time for today's left
just being alive in the past is proof of
collaboration and worthy of a witch
burning and remember Joe was born less
than a hundred years after the end of
slavery so I want to feel bad for Joe
but then I remember this if your
publishers don't want one of the class
people vote they don't want black folks
owned Unchained Wall Street
they're gonna put y'all back in Chains
Biden could smear with the best so what
goes around comes around and today
everything comes around until Joe goes
away speaking of going away I would
offer up a moment of silence for mr.
Eric Schwaab well but no one wants to
lose a moment of silence from this show
but let's just you want to just show his
exit whatever we have to be honest about
our own candidacies viability do an
American author Louis L'Amour wrote in
the Lonely Mountain there will be a time
when you believe everything is over that
will be the beginning today ends our
presidential campaign but it is the
beginning of an opportunity in Congress
with a new perspective
Jessie Rees crust as I am a little upset
because I had Gillibrand the first to
drop but you had slow well yeah so again
Gregg wins and I lose I'm getting used
to it
on the Biden situation big difference
between Trump and Biden is this Biden
runs away from controversy and Trump
runs towards it and if you look at Trump
over the last couple years even
controversial things in his own party
he's hung tough on tariffs on the border
on the travel ban even his personal
so-called scandals he's really dug in
hard
whereas Joe Biden over the course of
four months basically has changed
positions or apologized on the Hyde
Amendment segregationists Anita Hill
inappropriate touching the Chinese
threat and this is the worst form of
apology because it's insincere it was
forced he didn't want to give it but he
had to give it and it looks like the
base is leaving him instead of him
leading the base he doesn't look like he
has the presidential timber where as
president Trump highest approval rating
he's gotten so far in the latest poll by
ABC Washington Post and I think that's
because the Mulla report has kind of
slowed things down you've had two very
successful overseas trips and Europe and
Asia
and the American public is kind of
beginning to contrast the president with
some of these other Democrats and
they're looking at him more favorably
plus the great economic news coming out
in June also America's female soccer
team won the World Cup thanks to Donald
Trump one yes yes we've led them to
victory yeah Katie not talking about the
Golden Boot I think a lot of Americans
like to give him the gold what's the
disapproval I will say this I think Joe
Biden still getting back into fighting
shape into campaign mode if you were so
he's on the way back and you hear this
criticism inside the Democratic Party
that he's slowed down I mean slow to
announce and he's still getting back to
his agent oh Joe but I will say that
what you do get is Donald Trump
Katie immediately tweeting about Joe
Biden he's not tweeting about Harris
right he's not tweeting about Pocahontas
he's tweeting about the guy that he's
worried is gonna beat him get him the
golden boot and that's Joe Biden so is
slow Joe have his mojo or is it a no go
look I mean how long is it going to take
Joe Biden to get into the race I mean
this is crucial timing he's at the top
of the the pack and he knows because of
that the chances from going down are
inevitable and he has to hold on to that
front that front spot he keeps leaning
on the Obama legacy and not only is
Obama not endorsing him but people in
the Obama camp are running away from him
as fast as possible and also openly
criticizing him I mean David Axelrod
again over the weekend saying I don't
know if this guy can make it to the end
based on all of his flip-flopping and in
the end what's the point of having a
moderate lane in the Democratic primary
if Joe Biden is just going to
continually change his positions and
when he gets to a general if he becomes
the nominee which is not inevitable by
the way what is he going to actually run
on considering he's changing all of his
positions he says I apologize for what I
said a couple weeks ago
well this was a position that you took
over the course of 40 years of your
career in the Senate so are you
apologizing for that too I mean what is
his platform I'm not sure that's a good
point he's turning the moderate Lane in
to Lombard Street very curvy yes run
another road okay this new political
climate does not seem to suit him well
yeah so he's been running for office for
40 years when you are running as the
vice president on a ticket where
President Obama is super popular you're
running on that ticket and he was a good
vice president for him I'm not saying
that she wasn't but that doesn't
necessarily mean that you are then the
great the best candidate for this
political moment that we are in and
think of the progression he said what he
said he then he told Cory Booker that
Cory Booker should apologize like I'm
not gonna apologize I was like oh he's
got some fight in him and then he does
an interview in which he says I didn't
expect for them to come after me then he
says oh actually I'm sorry so you think
about this debate in the next three
weeks
it is likely just the way things work
out that Elizabeth Warren will be on the
stage with him so if I'm her I'm
thinking what else could I get him on
how can we get him on that progression
and you could go back 45 years whatever
and find something that he's done to
help support Wall Street right or some
hour Bernie Sanders will go after him on
health care and you could see the same
type of progression happening to the
point where you're I think you were
saying that the the base is leading him
to positions that he doesn't necessarily
hold your point about the new terrain
there's it's it's a greater net it was
like when I took my driver's test I had
to use a car that was 20 years old
because I couldn't ride the car that my
wife had because I didn't understand any
of the gadgets it had like the rear-view
mirror movie thing yeah nothing so I had
in order to pass a test I had to use
like a Taurus from like 1999 so get you
to your destination yes you know for all
that we're talking about people so like
him I guess yeah people do like him and
he's I thinking you know going back to a
Jessie saying about that Washington
post/abc Paul I think he's plus 10 over
Trump in that poll nobody else is above
Trump in that poll except for like maybe
one or two but pretty within margin of
error is your point but I think that the
key to
you know as we were looking at bi and
today and the apology is to understand
that his base of support in the moderate
Lane that Greg's talking about the
Democratic Party remains very strong I I
hope it does that same Paul had Hillary
beating Trump by 13 points one just to
let you win was at the end there and 16
yeah not now I hope not